hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on increasing ms
productivity
a self-driving
mass spectrometer designed for non-mms
experts by patrick cronin an lc
application scientist at lgilend and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin i want to encourage everyone to
engage with us
you can submit as many questions as you
want during the presentation simply type
them into the ask a question box on the
left and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that support
tab found at the top right hand corner
or use the ask a question box on the
left
without further ado please joining me in
welcoming patrick conan
welcome patrick
hi welcome to agilent technologies
center of excellence in lexington
massachusetts and i'm patrick cronin i'm
an lc application scientist here at
agilent and i'm going to be talking to
you today about the newest single quad
in agilent's portfolio the lc msd iq
which you can see here
um as you're aware agilent has a long
history
in single quad
instrumentation we started back in 1997
and we've evolved the single quad
into
the newest lc msd series one of the
major changes here
from from our 6120 and 6130 is that you
can now stack the lcds directly on top
of the mass specs
one of the best additions to this lcmsd
is the lc msd iq which is our smallest
single quad mass spec um as you can see
here it's on our flex bench and this
card so the roughing pump in its quiet
cover the lc msd iq and the lc can all
be on one mobile station that can be
moved around the lab or to different
labs within your organization
in addition to the iq
which is the best transition for lc lcuv
as this clarification continues we also
have the lc msd which is our workforce
really great for mass directed
purification systems um and our lcmsd xt
which has an extended mass range up to
3000 amu which is great for
our impact proteins of large molecule
separation with decomposition
so when we look at the lc
lc systems that we have we have a whole
portfolio from 1220 to 1290 infiniti ii
what we're showcasing here is our newest
lc system which is the 1260
infinity prime
so we have a flexible pump up at the top
a
bio sampler with an integrated column
compartment which i'm actually not using
today because i have my 1260 mct here
which we'll get into a little bit as we
take a little deeper dive
diode ray detector here and then our
mass spectrum
so
what keeps lc and lcms users
right we collaborated with the atlanta
analytical scientists excuse me to um to
get some more feedback from the field
what you guys want from us
so um some samples are going to push us
beyond our limits right if we can't we
don't have a unique problem
it's a volatile sample
um we're concerned about hidden
impurities right what is inside that
sample
that's everything that we need to
um too much time refining methods so
taking these lcuv methods that we've had
that are validated and we've been using
for years and then transitioning them to
a mass spec method takes a lot of time
we have to know exactly how
to transition this method to change the
mobile phase to um
change our settings to make that spec
work
and then unpredictable that
downtime right we have a mass spec what
happens if we you know clog the needle
or or something breaks how do we how do
we fix it so
um mass effect is going to add certainty
clarity and confidence so if we look at
the inset here on this chromatogram we
have the uv chromatogram there and we
see three peaks great all right three
peaks we can run our purity check but as
we run through the mass spec
single ion
monitoring in the mass spec we see five
different
compounds when we monitor those ions
so we're detecting two more compounds
and when we do
a extracted ion chromatograph you can
actually see
lustrone and tracidone coalu but using
extracted ion chromatograms and single
iron monitoring we can pull them apart
and detect them even though they're at
the exact same retention time the ue
chromatogram you can't pull those apart
unless you physically separate them on
the column
so adding mass detection to your lab
right the easiest way is the lc msd iq
it's small it's compact it is the size
of an lc module when we say that it is
the exact size of a file sampler or
multi-sample
same depth same width width same height
so the total stack width 15.6
by 18.7 inches deep by 12 inches tall
and the bottles
so they're integrated with the lc stack
the other benefits here are we use 110
voltage so we can plug this directly
into the wall takes about 30 minutes to
pump down
so if you do need to use this mass
effect another lab down the hall and you
can unplug it wheel it down the quiet
cover connects to this the
flex bench ms and you can wheel it down
to another lab and plug it in and within
30 minutes be up and running and running
your samples
so now we're going to take a live look
at the system that's right here on front
so first
we have our lc
uh
prime 1260 prime lc a17 lc msd iq uh
this is our 1260 prime lc uh it has an
onboard degasser here a proportionate
valve for quantity buffer blending
uh one pump head here but each
pistons with independent motor drives so
we don't need a pulse down so we get
much less delay volume with this pump
right here is our inlet weaver so we
have a mixer prior to the long head
which gives binary like performance by
really mixing the motor plates doubling
before goes out to the auto sampler
and then here is the
um
automated purge valve so you can
encourage your system and then
automatically start flushing the system
including the column
this pump and the
lc stack is at 800 bar pressure range to
get a little bit higher pressure not
1300 bar power of the 1290 but we get
some better
pressure range here so we can take
advantage of some
micron columns for a little bit faster
separation
um moving down
if we look at the auto sampler
we open these doors here this is our bio
sampler so it's an 800 bar sampler here
pressure range we've expanded the
capacity so these trays slide out we
have 132 files versus the older file
sampler 100 capacity and onboard another
peristaltic pump that does a needle wash
before or after each injection
uh
this is designed so you no longer need a
wash button dynamic wash that will wash
the outside
for about two
and then also here this here is our
integrated column compartment
right now i'm not using this because i'm
taking advantage of some column
switching capabilities we have down
below but you can plumb up the two
columns in here and manually switch
between them you have two different
weapons that you'd like to cover
so with a pump an auto sampler and a
mass spec you have a complete system
temperature controller
so now down below here
if i zoom out back to my
full view
you can see our column switching valve
here i have three columns
this is a four column switch valve
i have three columns long to the fourth
is resolved uh
left for a violence
which is important what we're doing
we're doing uv only methods
we're on one around some including
possible different things then we want
to transfer over to mass effect we can
use this bike that's very fast for a
very fast flush system to get all the
salt help
and then from here we move on to our you
know diameter rate detector
whether you need it or not most people
will have a dyno brand line before a
single clock and then our lcmsd
down at the bottom
so the lc msd here we have our standard
electric spray source here
which the nice thing here this is the
the one source that works with this
system uh covered 90 of the molecules
that you need to ionize
but when you open it up here it
immediately goes to standby so you don't
have to worry about any shock to
your body any of your lab workers uh and
then inside here we have an on board
ever back with most of the mass vents
that are out there on the market and all
of the mass specs that have a base so
this is designed so if you do have a
salty sample you can divert or maybe
some crud or dmso or something in your
sample that you don't want to get to the
mass effect you can reverse divert the
first minute or so to waste so that you
keep your source clean the other nice
thing is the onboard tuning solution
here this will slide out so you can
change your tool solution or do any
maintenance on your solenoid valves here
this just floats away
and then the last thing down at the
bottom is our quiet cover for our
roughing
so the rough pump sits inside here keeps
everything quiet there's a fan in there
to keep the heat down
mitigate the uh temperature control and
then this wire cover slides in
underneath the flex bench ms
and then it locks in place so everything
feels at one thing
so
if we move on
we go back to the slides
if we're talking about the mass effect
one it's very small it's compact it's
easy to use right it fits right in the
lc stack you can move it around your lab
but it's also intuitive in
the software is very easy to
smart as well
so
the first thing we have is instrument
health tracking right so we want to know
similar to our iphone right the battery
in your iphone that starts to come down
and you know oh i'm at 20 it's going
into low power mode i got to find a
place to charge it right we want to
instill the confidence that this mass
spec is working well in your lab
so we have the instrument health
tracking here which will count down
depending on when the last time you did
your check tune was or an auto tune was
or when you need to check change your
detector you're going to have this in
your lab for 10 years you're going to
probably need to change out some of the
capillaries or the
ion injectors
detectors etc
and those can be done at pm's as well
and then this health counter will
distract things for you
so the early maintenance feedback the
emf is going to constantly monitor and
report the instrument performance and
then it's a clear user interface so that
you can see very quickly when you need
to do some maintenance
other part here is that the auto tune
and check tune can be scheduled so
rather than coming in and locking the
system and doing the tune manually you
can set this up so that because this
tune solution is here through the divert
valve can be plumbed right into the
source this system can tune every
morning or
every monday morning at 5am before
anyone comes in then you get in you see
the tune report you can make sure
everything is passed and then go about
your day
other thing i just mentioned was the ion
injector otherwise known as the
capillary right the capillary is here it
it takes the ions that are formed in the
source and feeds them back towards the
ion optics that are optimized
by
the the tune that we just talked about
so this is the ion injector you know it
can get dirty if you're running dirty
samples
it's a consumable just like a column can
get dirty and stop uh performing as well
so can the ion injector nice part here
is that when you take the capillary out
you no longer have to vent the system we
have a tool that screws onto the front
and pulls the capillary out you can put
a new one in clean the old one or just
have a spare on hand
and you can do this all yourself without
even mentioning
so
even the detector
is a toolless task right when you
it's tool
tool less in the sense that actually
changing the detector is tool-less but
you have to take the covers off and kind
of slide some things out so maybe the
one tool you need is a torx wrench that
undoes these two screws so that this
whole tray can slide forward and then
you have access to the side panels
so now
talking about the software right we
talked about the small you know the
small nature of the mass spec how it
fits in the stack how easy it is to use
we talked about
the early maintenance feedback and how
we're designing this so that you
know when your system is performing
optimally and we also have a software
the system works with openlab 2.5
which is a the newest software
platform that agilent offers
very simple very easy to use very
intuitive very uh acquisition
spans um it's the same
instrument control framework that's used
in
you know mass hunter and chem station
just advanced a little bit more in the
data analysis side
so if we talk about mass fat right we
have our uv methods we know how
these
um validated methods sodium phosphate
long gradients really good sharp peak
shape and and good purity results now
i'm going to put this mask back on
so how
am i going to build that method how am i
going to
transition from this uv method that i
have to a mass spectrum now the first
thing you're going to need to do is
change
from a non-volatile buffer to a ball of
a column because we have to evaporate we
have gas and temperature in here that's
going to evaporate
the mobile phase so we can't have sodium
phosphate so what a
good transition a good change very mass
spec friendly buffer would be formic
acid so that's probably the the first
place you're going to start is do a 0.1
or 0.05 percent formic acid in water and
acetyl nitrate right we'll transition
this method over
and then we want to run into our mass
effect but how do i know how to set all
this up there's temperature settings
there there's voltage settings there i
have no idea what to do
so
first thing is how can i make sure that
i'm seeing everything right we saw three
peaks in the uv and then five peaks in
the mass spec i want to see that but i
don't know how to do it so
the best thing we can do is use auto
reply so within the open lab cvs 2.5 we
have a feature called auto fire so the
first thing you have to do is just input
the master all right i know my the
analytes in here are
between 200 and 500 amu so that's where
i want the mass effect to scan so as
soon as you input the mass range the
mass spec is going to read the lc flow
rate that you
set in your method and then set
parameters to make sure that we can
desolvate all of that liquid that's
coming through
so in the acquisition method you can see
under the
single quad when you highlight single
quad you have auto applier now that's
the defaults the default is auto
required so as soon as you set up a new
method it's automatically going to be
here you set the mass range that you
want to look for this in this case 100
to 1000 and then automatically
the system
stuck here
there we go automatically the system
will make that change for you right
conversely if if you're a seasoned mass
spec user and you know how to set all
these features and you have methods that
you want to translate all you have to do
is click under advanced acquire on the
acquisition tab and it one will prompt
you do you want to leave auto acquire
and set your own
settings and if you do just make your
method exactly as you would with any
other map spec right set your capillary
voltage you set your
desolation temperature you set your
nebulizer uh gas flow all of those
things and you optimize your retention
that way
well here so if we take a look at an
application right so
my active pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical ingredient excuse me are
my apis pure right so we'll do a rapid
analysis um not so rapid that we're
transitioning um a validated method um
and then we'll look at the sample purity
workflow that's built into this system
right with report templates already set
in the in the
software
so here's our 1260 lc methodology we're
running an eclipse plus
longer 2.1 by 150 column uh 2 microliter
injection with 20 millimolar sodium
phosphate at ph 5.5 uh and then just
pure acetyl nitrate so i did this i just
found some um
validated published methods for some
over-the-counter you know pain relievers
right ibuprofen
so this is a 5 to 95 percent b percent
acn gradient
over 12 minutes
and the stop times about is 20 minutes
so the runtime is about 22 with the
injection cycle time and our pressure is
about 500 bar well within the range of
this pumping system because we have 800
bar of pressure
so if we look at our
api qc method we can see you know very
pure this is ibuprofen looks good right
uv only so we're taking
the assumption that that is ibuprofen if
we have injected ibuprofen we would
expect it to be there and then we see
the other impurities and we can see
where about 96
looks good
so
also over injects right so we want to
inject 20 microliters saturate the
ibuprofen p so we can see all these
smaller impurities and get some accurate
quantitation of how much is in there
right that's what we normally do we'll
do a low microliter injection high
microliter injection kind of look at the
relationship between the api and the
impurities of the sample
so
nice thing about the iq
is
again depending on the sensitivity and
the ionization efficiency of these
molecules we can run everything in one
method we'll transfer out the sodium
phosphate to formic acid
and then flush the system we can use the
same column
in this case what i have on the system
now that i just showed you it's actually
a smaller columns you can go a little
bit faster if we wanted to
um doing the same gradient and all we do
is change the mobile phase
and
change uh
add the iq the mass effect to the end of
it
we can now
set up these
settings on our own or use auto require
exactly as it's designed to be done so
we have the same runtime the same
gradient different hobo phase because
that's essential and then we're using
auto require so when you look at the
separation here
we have ibuprofen game reliever it's a
206.29 molecular weight
so when we put in the target formula of
c13h1802
we can run this method ibuprofen is
detected
at 7.076 minutes there's a extracted ion
chromatogram for the molecular weight in
the molecular ion
because we input that target formula
and now we can pull this out and based
on the uv
uh chromatograms we see we're about 90
percent pure because we're seeing some
of these other peaks here
now the nice part here is the uv peaks
in the late later looting
part of the chromatogram 9 to 12 minutes
they're not really showing up on the uv
here but you we can see them in the mass
spec and then we can even tease out some
more information maybe there's some
stuff in the sample that isn't uh being
detected right
but the nice part based on the formula
and the
sample report templates that are
automatically
included with the software we can input
our target formula and immediately get a
report that says is the target found and
is it pure and this is all set through
the data analysis processing
you can tell the purity cut off if you
want anything to be colored green you
can say i need it to be 95 here i have
it set to 80
so obviously the target is called green
it's found it's pure uh and i can go
along with my dick so
from
soup to nuts right you can plug this
system in in 30 minutes
you can be pumped down and ready to go
and using auto acquire you can translate
these uv only methods over to mass
effect friendly methods and use our
sample purity workflow to very quickly
find
target compounds or unknown compounds
in the matrix
um a couple of
innovation minutes that we have online
just the product overview similar to
what we did today the ventless
maintenance with the back shield so we
can change the ion injector
walk up with rapid submissions we
actually have walk-up software so you
don't have to set the method you can
just come up log in put a sample on and
and
expert user behind the scenes kind of
creates the methods that you allow the
walk-up users to use and then just a
general overview on open lab cds and a
couple of the changes between chem
station and cbs
um and then here is our technical
overview some applications uh again the
walk-up 4.0 technical overview
we have a lot of application notes out
on this system now it's about
about two years old a year and a half
old now so we're ramping up a lot of
people are using it there's a lot more
collateral out there that you can can
browse
but in general the goal of this system
is to be very easy to use very easy to
operate for even non-mass effect
textbooks right so anybody any uv user
any analytical chemist can input this
mass spec in their lab
and be up and running on data
so
with that i thank you for your attention
and
we will have a live q a if you have any
questions please join me and
like and answer them thank you very much
thank you patrick for that informative
presentation we will now move to the
live q a portion of our webinar if you
have any questions please go ahead and
submit them now our first question
we have coming already in from our
audience
when i'm transferring my uv method to
mass spec what is the most important
change to focus on
good afternoon sorry i'm uh
in the in the building here and i
in lexington i'm just taking my mask off
so you guys can hear me better um
so when you're transferring from uv to
mass spec the most important feature
before you even think about anything the
software or or changing settings is you
need to change the mobile phase some
uv-only methods have non-volatile
buffers or um
non-mass spec friendly modifiers like
phosphoric acid or
sodium phosphate different salts those
are not compatible with mass spec so the
first thing you want to do is make sure
that you have a mass spec friendly lc
method before you even start to adjust
the source settings and everything
afterwards
thank you so much and our next question
if i use the auto acquire and do not get
the desired sensitivity what can i try
next
um yeah so auto acquire is is designed
for someone who maybe has never used a
mass spec before so you want to walk up
to the system and you want to get some
sensitivity before you've even you know
read the manual right so it's designed
to to be a really quick uh way to do
that
if you've you know exhausted the auto
acquire and maybe you want to try to get
a little more enhanced sensitivity you
can start to adjust um
the
advanced acquire right i mentioned in
the in the presentation that if you
choose and you click on advanced acquire
it turns off the auto acquire and allows
you to adjust the setting so
maybe you know we've seen it before a
couple of a few compounds that we've run
um could be thermally labile so the the
gas temperature and the gas pressure is
designed based on the flow rate that
you're running but if your sample could
be thermally labile you may be degrading
it with the heat and the source so you
can start to adjust those those
temperatures the gas settings um the
voltages to try to
get a better sensitivity for your
compound
thank you so much we have one more
question now does the auto acquire can
it be working with an old model um like
an msd
so yes so we have um
[Music]
three models of
single quads right the the iq that i
just mentioned the lcmsd and lc msd
xt these um our evolution of of newer of
older models of the of the single quad
so the iq is designed to work with open
lab cds 2.5 or 2.4 and above and that
driver for the auto require was built
into that software for the iq only so
right now it's only available on the iq
and it's not backwards compatible to
the other versions of of software
or the other models that are that are
out there
thank you so much and we've got john
sawson joining us he just wanted to
comment perhaps adjusting the ph set the
module phase to be one to two ph units
different than the pkas of the analyte
do you want to comment on it yeah so
yes he was um that was in in really uh
response to the
uh mobile phase choices when you're when
you're looking to move from
a uh non-mass spec
non-mass spec friendly buffer if you're
trying to find something just setting
the ph one to two ph units different
than the pka of your analyte is usually
a good place to start doesn't have to be
formic acid or ammonium formate or
things like that that i had mentioned in
the presentation but enough
far enough away from the ph of your
pka of your analyte that you'll get some
ionization on that molecule
patrick this has been a great
presentation thank you so much for your
time today and for your important
research
do you want to provide any closing
remarks before we go to our audience
no i'd just like to thank everybody for
listening and thank you guys for putting
this all together
and as a reminder for our audience i
want to remind you that questions that
you did not have time to submit today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed via the email
address you provided the time of
registration thank you again so much
patrick and to everyone who participated
today we hope you will check out the
agilent exhibit hall and enjoy the final
presentation right after this take care
stay safe and stay healthy bye bye
everyone